these chairs are made from plastic
thread seemingly endless lines woven
into a sturdy piece of furniture what's
unusual is that they come out of a
printer dick founder Kui is the man
behind the idea it's not just the
creation of new forms that interests the
Dutch designer for me it's always about
the material and the structure that
should be new and she'll be interesting
and this is actually what what I want to
do as a designer at an old industrial
site 30 kilometres from Amsterdam
founder Kui has a workshop studio and
showroom under one roof
his company uses robotics technology to
print all its furniture this robotic arm
was once used in the auto industry
during his studies Vander coy spent 18
months adapting it until his first chair
was ready first Javier I was really
amazed and so happy that succeeded and
so nice that the chair has always been
made in a perfect speed without my
control that's kind of a relief
it works by applying layer after layer
of liquid plastic it takes up to three
hours until a chair is ready the raw
material is plastic particles they come
from old shredded refrigerators
it just makes me feel better and this is
not like I'm not the the guy that is
completely not harmful to the
environment because I Drive a car
I wore my house on gas I think but it's
I think it's if it could be done then
it's always nicer to do it from
reclaimed materials his creations cost
between 300 and 2000 euros museums all
over the world are interested in his
furniture his works have been displayed
in New York London and Berlin
other Dutch designers are also
experimenting with the 3d printing
process your aslam on for example has
designed a chair that is made of plastic
puzzle pieces all made with a printer
the designer also works with other
materials his special robots can print
metal the first piece of furniture made
with this technique is the dragon bench
it is a way to see way more foster in
real the thing you and visualized and
this way designing is more from the
screen into the into the wheel but it's
also when you had the first one made you
could also easily make more everybody
could start up their own little company
with traditional 2d printing in
conventional furniture production
plastic resin is poured into a metal
mold all pieces created in this process
are identical but that's not how dark
band Ocoee does it each piece of his
furniture is unique
the designer can alter the plans at
anytime on the computer a program
translates them into digital data that
can be read and implemented by the robot
but every detail counts
you cannot just cross lines or you
cannot you have to consider that the
lines every mistake you make is going to
be ugly as much in the chair so yeah you
have to guide the lines perfectly 3d
technology is not just a means of
production but also a means of
inspiration for the 30 year old well as
a little house we would certainly want
to to create and not with typical 3d
printing but adapting the technique in
that way that is actually logical that
you do it to create a house with this
technique now it should not tell more
yeah he's not interested in standardized
production imperfections are an integral
part of dirk van der Koei's designs